would you rat out a professor for saying
something you disagree with a new survey
found three quarters of college students
agreed that professors should be
reported to the university if they say
something students find offensive 81 of
liberal students and 53 percent of
conservative students agreed and it
isn't just professors who college
students are eager to rat on over half
of them think fellow students should be
reported for saying something offensive
and what counts as offensive statements
many Americans agree with things like
opposing coveted vaccine mandates or
disagreeing with affirmative action and
this isn't just a hypothetical last year
a Hamline University Professor lost her
job after she showed students a medieval
drawing in Muhammad in an art history
class even though she gave multiple
warnings a disgruntled student reported
her when college students hear something
they disagree with they should try
having a conversation not running to the
administration I thought snitches get
stitches but now they get diplomas